foreign
hi Timothy welcome to the Ramsay show
well hello there hey how can we help
great uh so I'm gonna get married in
July which is very exciting very awesome
good and they're getting married into
fifty thousand dollars of student loans
that's awesome okay you discussed it and
uh that's behind us they're gonna make
different choices going forward so the
really Crux of the question here is
it's a relationship question built into
a money situation so I have a
hundred thousand dollars in mutual funds
and just regular brokerage account so
clearly I could just cash amount with
off the debt my concern is that the
loans are on my future mother-in-law's
name the her loans their Parent PLUS
Loan and so I don't want to be the rich
boyfriend that comes in plays off all
the debt and then just has that status
of You Know Rich boyfriend then
it's gotten on the title to something
like that
hmm
you you don't you want you don't want
the status of you don't want to look
like a snob is that what you're saying
yeah I want to this basically I didn't
know they've had trouble with um
finances before and it's tight and hard
for them so I don't want to
I want to guess I prove that I can work
hard and
be smart and it wasn't just all given to
me by my parents or grandparents which
some of this money has so it wasn't all
money that I've earned okay how much of
her student loan debt is her parents
debt
that's Parent Plus
so all four years are Parent Plus Loans
it's been agreed that he and her will
pay off the last two which is all which
is fifty thousand dollars a bank plus
the first two are like
45. you were not in on the deal
it would give us a greet originally when
they did this that she would pay
that your fiancee would when she got out
of college you'll pay the first two and
Mom and Dad would pay the second two
there was a grid when they were
finishing High School yeah okay so
that's the deal she made with her mom
and dad
yep okay because she's not legally
obligated but she has a handshake with
them that she's going to do this
oh yes exactly right and you're talking
about paying off the portion that she
gave them a handshake and agreed to pay
right only
yep not the first half okay the other
the other's all mom and dad and it's
still on Mom and Dad after this story is
over right
yep okay yeah that's a no-brainer after
the honeymoon write a check and pay them
off don't pay the mom and dad pay the
loans off
right right and as far as whether you're
a snob or not here's how you don't be a
snob don't be a snob
just don't even bring it up I mean can
you emotionally let this go and not roll
your eyes at them when they're doing
something else stupid because you paid
this off
uh I think but I could it'd be
yeah it's my dance
on my mind would be okay I could handle
that if you
yeah I I'm confused as to you must have
gotten some smoke somewhere along the
way did you pick up a dinner tab one
time or something and there was kind of
some awkwardness around the table
so we were planning on being
missionaries and fundraising our salary
when I asked if I could uh propose and
the father-in-law was not super thrilled
about that and so in the end I was I
told him that I had this account I was
like look if I mentioned this for two
years there's no way we're gonna like be
totally screwed because uh the worst
case scenario this could float us which
is what we were planning on signing into
your contract that's all true we're not
going to be missionaries we're gonna
have regular jobs
so I think that's kind of
see here's what I'd record I would
recommend this as early as possible in
your marriage that and this is harder
for some people than it is for others
but
at the end of the day you and your wife
have to build a marriage together
and you can't be responsible for the
regulation of the adult emotions in your
life around you
so okay what you have is a debt
you're gonna pay that debt off because
you're a person of character of an
Integrity you worked your butt off to
set yourself up in this situation and
you got some gifts to set yourself
yourself up in a situation great
if he wants to turn and
get offended by it or feel less Superior
whatever he wants to that is his and the
earlier you can learn to not try to
control that the more peaceful your
marriage is going to be moving forward
that makes sense
and expect it expect it if you know it's
coming back then it's coming back cool
and it's just you're gonna be ready
emotionally when that happens and you
just smile and Nod and wander off to the
other room and pour a cup of coffee yeah
because you know it's coming you know
you know it's going to come and then
then you're not the snot the beautiful
thing about this conversation Timothy is
you're self-aware enough and you kind of
felt that rise up in you in that other
conversation that you kind of went oh
that could happen again so John's right
you smelled smoke before and so you're
self-aware enough to go I really need to
steal myself I need to put some Backbone
in myself on this issue because this is
probably coming at me and that's really
the question you were answering that's
right asking and uh John's answering and
so yeah because we know the right thing
to do is to pay the debt off yeah you
need to pay the debt off because that's
it whether it's a legal debt a moral
debt an ethical debt uh which is only
the last two
um it becomes your debt when you get
married and you're going to write a
check when you get home from the
honeymoon and be you know if she had a
car loan you'd pay it off if she had a
student a regular student loan you pay
that off whatever it is and
you're thank God you're aware before
going into this exactly what you're
getting into and you're willing to do
that
and she's worth it and it's just and now
we go forward
and then by the way when you get the flu
she'll make soup
so for in for richer for poorer
and sickness and in health
and the old book of common prayer that
you would have heard maybe in the 40s or
50s at a wedding says unto thee all my
worldly Goods I pledge
beautiful old marriage foul seldom used
now in an I'm independent culture but
I'm married but I'm independent but I'm
married
there's your problem it's not real
there's your sign
Timothy you're doing good I'm really
proud of you I think you're very
self-aware you you kind of you're
observing this you're going I could do
this wrong and how do I not do it wrong
the fact that you're asking the question
is probably a sign you're not going to
do it wrong
uh if you just didn't even know it was
there and you were oblivious that's
probably when you're going to step in it
and put yourself in his shoes not to
excuse a behavior but to give yourself a
little gap between the stimulus and
response
he's got a guy coming in and writing a
check for his daughter that he couldn't
write
that's gotta hurt a little bit it's
gonna hurt a little bit and I can
imagine that stinging a little bit and
so so be it I get it it's it's silly
it's inappropriate but I get it it's
kind of interesting too that he was
questioning their financial plan oh he's
broke it's incredible but that's that's
that's I mean that's where the that's
where the the biggest jeers come from
the cheap seats right
that's where the complainers come throw
the peanuts only from the cheap seats
exactly oh this is how it works man I'm
telling you so yeah that um
it's it's a sweet Spirit you've got on
this Timothy I think you're going to be
just fine I think you're doing a good
thing and um thank God it's not 500 000.
you know or more likely the way I
usually hear this call is I don't have
that money oh yeah and father-in-law is
asking for the check right now yeah
where's my money well good luck with
that I don't have it I didn't do this
dude you did so now I can write that
check yeah yeah that's that's and so it
becomes this push thing this push and
pull and uh this is why let me tell you
student loans are evil Parent Plus Loans
are straight from the pit of Hell
because
the parent is borrowing the money for
the kid to go to school and then there's
all these side deals or these unsaid
unmet expectations or there's a deal and
then suddenly you get a nice job out of
college and then surely yeah I mean look
at him he makes all this money ought to
pick it up I told him I pay it but I
mean look at that gym it's it's just
these things have not only the problems
and the weight of a student loan but
they have the ability to drive wedges in
families as well right and in
relationships it's straight up from the
pit of Hell this student loan thing is
man it it hey Congress
stop making them
you're screwing up a whole generation or
two stop it
there's nothing good coming out of this
they've only got a degree in left-handed
puppetry stop it